- [Tat] So this is the
beginnings of
the business offices.
We'll come back and tour this.
This got redone a
couple of years ago.
- Looks nice.
- Yes, yes.
June 11th I'll be
20 years in this piece.
- That's amazing.
- So I run Funk Flexes digital
as well as
produce this radio show.
- [Gary] I love it.
- [Tat] So yeah, we throw
some really good things
in this space.
- Hey, hey.
Hey hey.
What's up, man?
Good seeing you.
- Greetings, Techsters.
Welcome to Hot in Tech,
the number one tech show
in hip-hop, brought to you
by the birthplace of hip-hop,
Hot 97.
- Facts.
- I'm Jesse K.
This is my co-host Tat Wza
AKA the Hip-Hop Tech Wizard.
- What's good, B?
- Today we've got the ultimate
hustler in digital, period.
He's got his hands in
everything behind the scenes
but is quickly becoming
the face of business tech,
Mr. Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Gary, what's good, my dude?
- I'm good, guys, thank
you so much for having me.
- No, thank you for coming.
- What a year, 2016.
- The best.
I love how everybody is
like this is the worst year,
I can't wait for
this year to be over.
I love this year.
- Yeah, it's been
a great year for you.
- I'm talking about
it's always a great year.
If you're alive,
it's a great year.
You could decide
it's a bad year.
But as a matter of
fact, this is not the best
business year I've ever had.
But it's the best year
because what's the alternative?
- Facts.
Yo, I love your energy.
I love it.
- I appreciate it.
- There's so many times
I'm out here telling people
like yo, you know, get up,
pull your
bootstraps, get up here
and get out and do
something with yourself
because there's no limit.
It's you that's
stopping yourself.
And I see that in
your messages all the time.
- To me I always
get an extra bolt
when I'm around
hip-hop and urban demo
because they
understand it better.
Like, it's unbelievable
how much I in my brain,
this is a forewarning, all
of you are about to say pff.
It's unbelievable
how much in my brain
I think that my son,
white kid Upper East Side rich
is at disadvantage
over minority from Harlem.
If that kid,
if she or he understood
what eating dirt, how much of
an advantage that actually is,
I lived it.
I came from nothing,
so, yeah I wish they knew.
So every time I'm in a
setting like this versus,
I'm in a suit
which is as you guys know
everybody's making
jokes today, twice a year,
funeral and I had to be at the
New York Stock Exchange today.
Like, it's unbelievable to
me how much people don't get it
and realize how much
opportunity there is.
And when you come from
zero, you have an advantage
in 2017, not a disadvantage.
And I'm trying to get
people through sheer will
and putting out
content to understand that.
- [Tat] Facts.
- And you first got on my radar
when one of your
companies Wine Library TV
was popping on YouTube.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And you came out
with this rant talking
about the
entrepreneurial spirit of tech
being very like the
early days of hip-hop.
- [Gary] You remember that?
- And I was like,
this guy is one of us.
He's talking hip-hop and
tech at the same time.
But that was
like eight years ago.
- 2008 I made a video,
2009 I made a video
that said tech is about
to be what hip-hop '85 was.
You know I grew up
in Jersey in Edison.
So you know, I'm cliche
white kid that was affected
by Yo MTV Raps, part
of that first generation.
Adidas no,
that's what I grew up in,
a lot of diversity back then.
And so I remember when
I thought the Phat Boys
or Beastie Boys or
KRS-1 were famous
but I knew that
the world didn't.
And now the biggest
rappers in the world
are the most famous, right?
- [Tat] Yeah.
- And so that's
what I saw in tech.
When Kevin Rose and
Zucks and Sacca and Ev Williams
I'm like okay, I know they're
gonna be big and they're cool.
But the world doesn't yet.
I remember telling
Kevin Rose who's the founder
of Digg.com which is the
big site back in the day.
I said you need to
understand that we're gonna be
like the baseball
players from the 50s and 60s
where they made less
money in their whole,
Willie Mays made less
money in his whole career
than an average baseball
player makes in a year now.
- But one of the
legends in the game.
- And so I said
to Kevin, I said,
you're gonna be a
legend in the game
because he was a Web 2.0 legend.
I said, but you need
to understand one thing.
The next you in seven years
is gonna be dating supermodels.
And I was making
that joke and sure enough.
Evan Spiegel
marrying a supermodel.
So I think you're right.
That was the video
where I first kind of like
put that out there.
And I'm impressed
that you sniffed out
what I was up to.
- That's how you got on my radar
and you've been
steady grinding ever since.
- And prior.
- It feels like this year though
with maybe the rise of Snapchat
and maybe your
content engine heating up
that you've really kind of
become a household name
in this space.
- Yeah this was the
very big year for me.
Like if you look at even
basic vanity numbers of growth
of like my social numbers
between D-Rock and I
getting serious you know.
Yesterday or the day before
was the one year anniversary
of DailyVee, the
documented thing that I do.
We got serious.
I got to a place
where VaynerMedia,
for a lot of
you that don't know,
I have a company that
does social media advertising
and digital advertising for the
biggest brands in the world.
It got big enough where
I could afford me being the face
of it to put some dollars
into people against my brand.
And yeah this
year everything changed
in a pretty significant way.
- So I first saw you.
And forgive me
for just catching up.
- No worries.
Back to this point, most
people are just catching up.
- A little less then a
year ago, right after CES
I had my first
episode DailyVee 003.
A friend of mine
from Silicon Valley
said hey, you
remind me of somebody.
I want you to
check out GaryVee.
So I watched this
episode while driving in my car.
And you said
something that just took me.
I was like, this is the guy.
- It's about to get crazy.
Honestly, in a
different way, DJ Khaled
is the Ashton Kutcher
moment for Twitter.
- You said DJ Khaled
was the Ashton Kutchner
for Snapchat.
Meaning what Ashton
Kutchner was to Twitter,
introducing it to people
and getting it out there
Khaled was to Snapchat.
And I knew, Khaled is a
really good friend of mine.
I'll even say, and
I'll put this out there.
Right before Khaled
exploded on Snapchat,
he was in New York and we
were snapchatting in the studio.
He was here.
He had just popped
the term major keep
with Flex on Hot 97.
- [Gary] Yep, yep, yep.
And we were using Snapchat.
And he went back and figured out
how to use Snapchat for
him and became the king.
- 100%.
- [Tat] So when I saw you
say that, I was like,
this guy, man.
- You knew that I knew, right?
- [Tat] Yes.
- Because it was still early.
That was January 5th.
You know, Khaled really popped.
I'm really in my shit.
You know, can I curse on this?
- [Tat] Of course, do you.
- Okay, good.
November 13, 16,
that's when his stuff
really started getting going.
So it's six weeks in.
But 'cause I was
there with Ashton
and I was there,
okay this is the guy
and this is the platform.
And by the way, I've been
pressuring, back to music,
back to all your homies,
somebody's gonna
be that for Musical.ly.
There still isn't a
mainstream celebrity
that just decided to own.
And it's so crazy.
Musical.ly is such a
thing to win for a musician
because you can
win the entire
11 to 16-year-old
girl ecosystem.
And I'm just yelling at
some of my famous music friends
like do this, do this.
So Khaled was the
guy that figured out
how to storytell on a
platform that was about
to become mainstream.
Ashton did that on Twitter.
And someone's
gonna do that on Musical.ly
and then House
Party or something else
or something that's
gonna be invented next year.
But there's always gonna
be a Christopher Columbus
And, I know
you're tight with him,
the economics are crazy.
The amount of
money Khaled's making--
- [Tat] It's retarded.
- knowing how hard he's worked.
I'm also, I pay
attention enough.
The grind, the spinning
night after night, the grind.
And he doesn't fly.
The grind, the grind.
To think about
the endorsement deals
and the biz dev deals and
the money that's being pumped
into his world,
it's a lesson for
everybody listening.
And you know,
this isn't just for people
that have Khaled's fame.
All the aspiring
hip-hop artists like pop
where everybody actually
is and then you got a shot.
- So we're gonna
talk about 2017.
This episode's
gonna be futurist.
It's gonna talk
what's coming next.
Starting with CES.
Where Tat just first
learned about you last year.
What do you see for 2017's CES?
How does that set the tone?
- You know what's funny?
Specially cause
I know a lot of people
would just be
learning about me right now.
I'm not Nostradamus.
Right, I love people
that think I am but I'm not.
And so the
answer is I'm not sure.
I'll tell you what I'm
paying attention to right now.
After School,
for high school kids.
House Party,
I already mentioned it.
Marco Polo.
There's things that are popping.
But Anchor and
Peach, and Yik Yak,
there's always
been these things.
There's nothing
yet that is like 100%.
I mean I was paying
attention to and talking about
Snapchat for two and a half
years before it got loud.
You saw the fat me in
2012 talking about the vid--?
So there's nothing that is like,
there's nothing at
least right this second
that I would put my name
on saying 2017's the year of.
I mean I didn't know that
Instagram was gonna follow
and copy features from Snap.
Like you never know.
What I think I'm good at
and what you've probably seen
the last decade is
when I taste it,
I'm like a shark with blood.
You know, sharks are crazy.
Like a little,
- [Tat] A mile out.
- Like a mile out,
like a little speck of
blood and they're like pfft.
- Yep.
- That's what I'm good at.
When I feel that, when
I taste that blood in the water,
I'm so fucking on it.
It's 24, I shut
down in December
on my family vacation
and spent every
minute dissecting Snapchat.
'Cause I knew Khaled had popped.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
If Khaled's popping, this
is really double good for me
because the way he rolls,
that's kind of similar,
we've got our
differences but like,
the thing that the
kids are attaching to,
that motivation
like, I'm living that.
- [Tat] Right.
- Like for real.
I only do that.
I don't and DJ.
That is me.
That is what I do.
And so I think that that's
what I'm paying attention to.
I don't know what's next.
But I'm always
circling those waters.
And don't let somebody
drop a little ounce of blood
'cause I'm going 24/7
at it once I taste it.
- [Tat] Facts.
So that was leading
to the next question, right?
I was gonna ask you,
Snapchat and Instagram,
what do you do?
- [Gary] Both.
- And we kind of
figured you'd say that.
So what do you do first?
- [Gary] Both.
- [Tat] At the same time?
- Yep.
- [Tat] You're not going
Snapchat then taking that video
and putting it on Instagram?
- I mean, honestly,
that's just a cadence.
That's just a moment in time.
That's however you
feel which one you like.
But anybody who's
listening right now
that wants to
make something happen.
You're gonna build the next
biggest clothing line, both.
You wanna get some new
customers for your bakery shop?
Both.
You wanna get a job interview
at a social media shop?
Both.
Like if you have ambition,
your actions have to match that.
And too many
people are just like
not putting in the work.
Their mouth is way ahead
of their fucking reactions.
Like really?
You're gonna be the
greatest NBA player of all time?
Why, 'cause you think
you got a little handle
on the weekends?
You need to shoot 15,000
free throws before
school every day.
- [Tat] Facts, love it.
- And so to me,
the answer is both.
And it's not even a
fact, people in business.
Like if you're a normal person.
If my brother-in-law
Alex Klein is like
what should I do for my life?
I don't care, one or the other.
But if you're a businessperson
or you have ambitions
or you wanna run for office
or whatever you wanna do,
both always and Twitter.
And Facebook.
And Youtube, and Soundcloud.
And, and, and, and.
- Do you think the
spectacles will help Snapchat?
- I do.
I think, here's my
big macro POV on this.
Snapchat is the
first social network
that has a chance to be a brand.
People think about Snapchat the
way they think about Yeezys.
The way they
think about Soulcycle.
think about Starbucks.
It's a brand.
And that's what these
glasses, these spectacles
have a chance of doing
if they pop and they hold.
Wall Street, business people,
the people that roll with me
are not just gonna
think and compare it
to Instagram and Facebook.
They're gonna compare it
to Instagram and Facebook
and Under Armour.
And that's a place
where they wanna be.
Because then all of
a sudden money goes up.
Then all of a sudden the
company's worth more money.
And so to me, as a
company that has IPO ambitions
and wants to be in the
stock market next year,
that's a big deal.
- You saw that with the lines.
They were crazy
for the spectacles.
- And they work
really well, we love them.
I'm super big
into consumer gadgetry.
So I think that they
are what Google Glass
should have been to consumers.
- But the reason
they were, is Google.
And this is, for
everybody who's listening,
this is a great segue and
I'll take it to a macro level.
This is about knowing your DNA.
This is where you
have to know yourself.
Let me explain.
Google was started by two nerds.
- [Tat] Mhmmm.
- So when they make a
consumer product, it was nerdy.
You ever see the picture?
Like if you're
listening right now,
Google, Google Glass.
Like you don't
wanna hang with that kid.
Snapchat, snap made spectacles.
That's made by Evan Spiegel.
He's dating a supermodel,
he was a cool LA kid.
- The cool kids.
- Like he's 25.
The way they rolled it
out, the vending machines.
It was a PR play.
It was like marketing,
it's branding.
It had a hell of a
lot more Nike in it
than it had Apple.
And even Apple's
crossed over and has that
but Snapchat's at a
whole different level
and so I mean, straight up,
if Snapchat is successful
with this at scale,
and every 16 to 26
year old is wearing them
and is into them,
and the real play is
definitely gonna be Summer Jam
and Coachella.
And like when the
summer comes around,
if East Coast kids
are wearing those glasses
to their vacation,
then they've got it.
And now all of a
sudden you've got a debate are,
in the same way that
nobody thought that Nike
would get
knocked off by Yeezys.
Like, are Snap sneakers
the hottest thing in 24 months?
That's why this matters so much.
Because they're
going into brand,
not just tech platform.
Especially in the
context of the people
that would listen
to something like this.
People that listen
to something like this,
they understand flavor.
They understand swag.
And that's not just
about how good a product is
and that matters.
- Yeah.
- Can we talk a
little about Amazon?
- We can talk about
anything you want, my man.
You got me.
- Echo has been
huge for the holidays.
- I love it, I agree.
- How does that,
and the drone culture
that Amazon's building.
- Amazon's a beast.
- Do you think that
the Echo changes the game
in term of content and how?
- I sure do.
Yep, easy.
When you're brushing your teeth
and you're down to the
last piece of your toothpaste
and you say Alexa,
reorder my toothpaste.
Whoever Amazon made the
deal with on the other side
is gonna sell
you that toothpaste.
And that is worth quadrillions.
That's more than billions,
that's more than trillions,
that's quadrillions.
And so for me, it's huge.
AI, voice activation.
Like here's a thing
that a lot of youngsters.
If you're listening, you're
under 25 that you can't know
because this has
always been your life.
But old cats like me, 40
like need to understand, right?
We just started.
Like, does everybody
understand what's going on here?
We've just started.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- Technology's
not going backwards.
- [Tat] Facts.
Like all these parents that
don't want their kids on iPads,
I want my kid on
an iPad 24/7/365.
- [Tat] They learn faster.
- Not only do they learn faster.
What world do you
think they're gonna live in?
- [Tat] Yeah.
- Like what world?
Run outside and play?
- You're giving them
a disadvantage by
not teaching them this early.
- Hundred.
Like what do you think
your kids are gonna be doing?
So I think voice, AI, AR,
VR, all that stuff is coming.
I don't think it's at scale.
I think Alexa is the first
consumer product that has scale.
So I think a lot, you know.
It's fun now.
It's fun to walk
in and be like yo,
put on that Chance album.
And they do,
that's cool, that's funny.
We haven't had that before.
But it's gonna get way
more serious than that.
Alexa, fill up my car with gas.
Now all of a sudden, who's
gonna invent the Uber for gas
where you don't
have to go to a station,
but gas comes to you.
And the reason you did
that was because of Alexa.
See how I'm thinking?
- I didn't even think of that.
- Of course not,
that's why I'm the best,
no I'm just kidding.
No, honestly on a very, but
this is how my brain thinks.
Think two chess moves.
Like I know what's
in front of us, right?
I met my wife on J date.
In 2003 if you went
on the internet dating,
you were the
biggest, weirdest nerd
living in your mom's basement.
I wasn't scared because
I already played the chess games
and said everybody's
gonna do this, got it?
- Yeah.
- And so that's it.
That's what everybody
listening has to do.
If you wanna make
money, you pay attention.
If you wanna be rich,
you pay attention
to what's going on now.
If you wanna be wealthy,
like all time wealthy,
you need to understand
what's gonna happen
next after this
and so we need to understand
what happens with these norms.
And so I think
Alexa's a big deal.
I think anybody who's
lucky enough to be able
to afford that, 'cause
that's a luxury in their home
and uses it will see
how their behavior changes.
And then what's gonna
happen is the same reason
my five year old,
my four and a half year old
comes to the TV
screen and swipes it
and is blown away by why
it's not doing something.
Everybody listening
right now, in six years
is not gonna accept things
not being voice-activated.
You're gonna text that way.
You're gonna talk that way.
You're gonna order, like.
I mean, listen, the
headphones are out now.
I don't have them.
They're out and about, right.
It's gonna be voice activated
'cause all we
care about is speed.
And if I could say it
faster than I could text it,
then I'm good.
- [Tat] Yeah, it's comfort.
- That's why texting exploded.
It's faster than talking.
But if you're just walking,
or if you're driving
and you need to pick up
your kid or do the laundry,
if you've got your
earpieces in and say, Siri,
order my laundry.
Everybody's gonna
have basically an assistant
at their fingertips.
You're never gonna
forget anything anymore.
You're gonna
get everything done.
It's gonna be unstoppable.
- What with Google Home
coming into the space too
you can even ask questions.
- Google, Facebook,
Apple, Amazon.
These four, five, six,
seven biggest tech companies,
they're all gonna be playing.
- Yeah.
- They're all competing
against each other.
There'll be a
Facebook home and a Google home
and an Apple home.
They're all gonna fight for it.
- Yeah, Google just got
into the game with devices
and they're whole
different ecosystem together
and I just think
it's amazing, it's great.
But I've also
been preaching caution.
Like okay yes,
you have to do this.
But you have to do it, you
have to learn it the best way
and how it works for you.
So you're not just out here
giving away your information
or you're just not out
here doing it the wrong way
and looking like a fool.
- [Gary] But that's
everything, right?
I'm glad you're
giving that advice.
But when people ask
me about that stuff,
I'm like, well
let's talk about alcohol.
Let me give you advice.
Don't drink 80 fucking 40s.
You know, like in one
night, you know what I mean?
Everything in moderation.
- Now how long did it take
people to learn that though?
You know, you had
prohibition where everybody
thought to you know.
- That was religion, you know.
- [Tat] Well, yeah.
- But I think you're right
and that's exactly right.
But the other thing that
you learn is people are good.
In the last 15 years,
all of us giving away our data
doing all this,
there wasn't as much bad.
- [Tat] Right.
- This notion that everything's,
this goes back to the
opening line of this interview.
Things are good.
You wanna talk about,
and mainstream media
wants to talk about, and
people want to talk about
the small percentage of bad.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- I'm thrilled.
And by the way,
there's plenty of bad.
There's always
gonna be sexism and racism
and religion persecution.
There's always gonna be that.
That's how humans roll.
- [Tat] That's human nature.
- But anybody that wants
to level this conversation
up with me at a
macro level, it's better.
- [Tat] Yes. Facts, guaranteed.
1945 was not as good as today.
- If you were alive 10
years ago and cognizant,
then you know the difference.
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- This is also a great
year for the music business.
It's trending up.
- [Gary] I love that.
- It's great to see that final,
every aspect of
music is growing.
A lot of it has to do
with the streaming wars.
Spotify, Tidal, Apple.
- [Gary] Apple Music, yep.
- Which on are
you leaning towards?
Which one do you got?
- Music is a place
where I don't like to talk
a lot about.
- [Tat] Hmmm.
- Because I think one of the
great things that have happened
to me in the lat
four years is I don't talk
about shit I don't know.
And it's made me real popular.
People pay attention
because you know what,
- You're not wasting their time.
- When I talking my mind,
you wanna talk about Alexa,
you wanna talk about Facebook,
you wanna talk about Instagram,
bring anybody here.
Put Zucks in
here, bring them all.
You wanna talk about music?
There's a lot of
people that understand it
better than I do.
I've always historically
stayed away from music
because of all the legalities
and things of that nature
and it made it scary for me.
Look, it's tough
to bet against Apple
because when you have
all the money in the world
sitting in your bank account,
you could buy Spotify
and Tidal 44 times over.
Right, so that's one
thing that I think about
to actually give you an
answer, not stay away from it.
You know what's funny?
I never thought
music was in trouble.
I thought the music
business that was built
where people that were
taking too much of the cut
was in trouble and that's good.
I like that.
I want the artists
to have more leverage.
Artists have more
leverage today than ever.
Because distribution's
been commoditized.
The game's changed.
So you go through a 10, 20
year period where it's scary.
People cry.
But on the other
side of it, it's better.
Of course music, to
me music is always great.
You know why?
It's one of the four or five
cultural pillars of society.
It will always be here.
People will always
care about music.
care about sports.
People will always
care about religion.
People will
always care about sex.
They're like only
a couple of things
that people will
always care about.
Music's one of them.
- [Jesse] Music crosses over
even all of those boundaries.
Some people might
not like sports.
Some people might not
be religiously segregated.
- It's you passion,
it's what you're into.
It's one of the things,
that's what he's saying
that if you're passionate
about music then
you're diving all in.
But you may be
passionate about sports
or religion or
whatever the case is.
We're passionate about tech.
- Yeah.
And you've always been
a music fan, obviously.
- But I'm a funny fan.
I'm not as educ, you know
it's funny to have Boyd here.
When Boyd became
AJ's friend in college,
I was like okay cool.
Some kid that
really knows hip-hop
and I'll really be
on top of it early.
Like I loved music for escapism.
So the reason I like
hip-hop as a person
is far more because
I like storytelling.
I'll give you a good one.
I don't really give a
shit about beats all that much.
Like the melodies,
like the harmony.
I like the story.
Like Biggie won me
because he told a story.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- Like I need storytelling.
When I listen to Kendrick Lamar,
I don't love like the music.
I don't need to like
listen to it 50 times.
- [Tat] You don't wanna
know who produced it.
- I don't.
And by the way, I'm
very aware of how important
and how other people
only go with producing
and only the music.
- [Tat] Yeah.
I need the story.
I need the lyrics and the words.
And what does it mean
and where is she or he going.
And so what music
does for me is when I go on
you know, a flight
like Saba, right?
I'm all about Saba right now.
So I'll listen
to the same two Saba
from the last thing
that he just dropped.
I'll listen to the same
two songs the whole six hours
to LA tomorrow.
That's what's gonna happen.
So I know a lot
of people listening,
'specially 'cause it's hot
and you said I love music.
Moose, my friend
Moose at Mount Ida College
who's a real hip-hop fan,
put me on to scarface,
was super into the Houston scene
two or three years
before Master P and everybody
started learning the south,
he would only
listen to a song once
and then cherish it.
He would cherish it
for like four weeks.
I heard "First of
the Month" by Bone Thugs
and played it
47,000 times in a row.
So I know that
I listen to music in a way
that hardcore music
people don't respect as much.
And I know that.
I get that and I love that.
I watch football.
I'll watch football tonight.
The Jets have a Monday Night
game when we're taping this.
And I'm gonna watch offensive
lineman's block technique.
I know people don't
watch football that way.
So you know, music
much like the other ones.
Obviously you, some
people go extremely deep
and really kind of know it.
But even me who's
not deep, needs it.
It's a part of his life.
And that's what I love about it.
- We have a guy here named Ebro.
Ebro in the morning,
he's also on Beats One.
Really big guy.
- Yep.
- He recently said something
that Snapchat was in trouble.
Now I kind of was
wondering that as well
with Instagram
doing what they did.
And we asked
about the spectacles.
I do think that
he's gonna bring it back.
- He said it because his
views are down on Snapchat
because everybody's
views are down.
- Right, right.
But my real question is
everybody's really talking about
how Twitter's in trouble.
Could Twitter become MySpace?
- Yes.
- Ooh, that's scary.
- For Twitter.
- Well it's scary for me too.
I've gotten used to
getting my news from Twitter.
- [Gary] Great, people used to
get their news from the radio.
- Facts, facts.
- Right?
I was used to getting
my music from MTV.
- So we just gotta
realign and get our news
from Snapchat or Instagram?
- Yep.
- Okay,
Twitter's in trouble, shit.
- And by the way,
Twitter is the reason
I'm even sitting here.
As you know, Twitter was
the first time I really popped.
Back in the day, I was
doing my wine show.
I jumped on Twitter,
I thought it was gonna be big.
It ended up being way bigger.
And I really
popped and transitioned
into business content
instead of wine content.
And so, I love Twitter.
Twitter is like the first
girl I ever hooked up with.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- You know what I mean?
There's always
that piece in my soul.
So it's hard for me to say that.
By the way, I sit on
a lot of Twitter stock.
I sold a lot of it
but I still have a lot
and I have a lot of economics.
- What can they do?
- They gotta change,
you gotta evolve.
Like Madonna did it right.
She reinvented herself 14 times.
That's why she
had a long career.
You got to reinvent yourself.
Twitter didn't make
product changes for six years
in its prime.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- Let's talk about sports.
When you're the best
athlete and you're like the guy
and you're like one
of the top 15 players.
Basketball I'm looking at Dunk.
You know @dunk at Instagram,
I'll give you some love.
He's got one of the
big basketball accounts
so I'm thinking about that.
I'm thinking about
basketball players.
Draymond Green, he's my buddy.
Draymond really worked
on his game every offseason.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- Ricky Rubio.
- [Tat] 'Kay.
- The flashy point
guard from Minnesota.
If he developed
his outside shot,
he would have been
a much bigger player.
He had all the
passing skills, the quickness.
He's got everything.
If instead of going to
Ibiza and fucking chicks
in the offseason, he
worked on his 18 foot jumper,
he'd be in the game.
Twitter was banging
chicks in the summer, got it?
- [Tat] Yeah, yeah.
- You like that?
It's a good analogy.
They love it back there.
That's what happened.
And guess what?
And then you deserve to lose.
'Cause some other kid isn't.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- Some other kid is
sitting in the rain on July 16th
taking 55,000 shots.
And that's what
Snapchat and Instagram did
and that's what happened.
- [Tat] I'm not gonna lie.
That's why I respect
Mark Zuckerberg so much.
'Cause he did not sit down.
- [Gary] He's a gangster.
He's the best!
- You think he's
letting something happen
and then even before
they make changes, months back
he buys Masquerade.
The people that made
the Snapchat filters.
And you're like oh
they got some shit coming.
And then he
dropped all this other stuff.
He hasn't even dropped that yet.
- [Gary] He's a
long term player.
He's a beast.
You know, it's
the same way I thought
about Hillary Clinton.
I would always say about
Hillary Clinton, yeah but,
Hillary will go to Russia,
go to a meeting with Putin,
slice his throat, walk out.
Putin's dead and
Hillary's like I don't know.
And I'm like shit,
I want that on my team.
And that's how Zucks is.
Zucks doesn't look the part.
- No, no.
Nobody who's
listening or watching right now
is scared of Zucks, curly
haired Jew kid walking in.
You'll be dead.
He will kill you.
Like when it comes to
business, what he does?
He will kill you.
Oh you copied my shit, and?
- Yep, do something about it.
- You want to
talk about real kill,
you want to convey
it in hip-hop?
He rolled up on
you in the street,
punked you, took
your fucking wallet,
looked in your face
and said do something.
- He pulled up on him.
- That's what Instagram
just did. Now, it's Evan's call.
Now Evan either
doesn't do something
and then that's how it
ends and we all know that.
Or he does.
We're about to find out.
- Snapchat, before
Instagram did this,
they answered
everything so fast.
And they haven't
answered Instagram yet
so I know they got
something big coming.
- 'Cause it's different.
Snapchat was innovating.
- Yeah.
- Now Instagram copied.
Now they have to
counter, but they did.
The glass is a real thing.
So it's a real battle.
Zucks, Ev, you
know Kevin Sistrom.
You're talking
about real winners.
This is a real fight,
this is a real fight, you know?
This isn't like you
hear, like a rap battle.
This guy versus this guy.
You know, like
this is a good one.
Not everybody's
sure what's gonna happen.
And the truth is both
are big enough to win.
So that's a whole 'nother thing.
Everybody loves,
you know when two artists
get into a battle, who wins?
Both.
- [Tat] Both, yeah.
- Unless you get
completely punked.
Hova addressed this in a song.
He tried to kill 50 cent.
- Yeah.
- But he was good enough.
Like, that's what's
so great about business.
It's so similar to hip-hop.
If you're good enough,
you will stay.
- [Tat] Yeah.
- And if you're not, you won't.
- [Tat] You're outta here.
- That's it.
So if Meek's good
enough, he'll stay.
Maybe he didn't
respond fast enough.
Maybe people that aren't
as deep into it as you are
think it's still over.
'Cause that's the
real issue with him
from a speed thing.
But I think that's right.
And that's how I think about it.
And so like when I talk
about three four years ago
liking Bezos and Zucks
more than Steve Jobs,
people got mad at me
'cause he was
on such a pedestal.
But to me they're like the
next generation entrepreneurs.
And both of them have had
monster three, four years.
And that's not gonna go away.
Because if you're
good, you're good.
- You touched on
something right, AIs.
And a show just
finished, Westworld.
Did you see Westworld?
- No, but I know
everybody's watching.
But I don't watch TV.
- Okay, well Westworld
pretty much at the end of the
day is about AIs
becoming self-aware.
- And then take
over and kill us?
- Pretty much.
- That's gonna happen.
- So Skynet is real.
- Yep, we're gonna die.
Like don't be
scared of the crazy guy
in the corner of your street.
Be scared of some robot
that's gonna slice your throat
in the middle of the night
that used to
pick up your laundry.
- So do some
survival packing now.
- Yeah I mean it's far away.
What I don't
know is when it flips
but this is just the beginning.
Do you know what
virtual reality porn looks like?
Let me save you guys time.
No dudes leaving the
house in 15 years ever again.
We will be a
world with no dudes.
They're all just
going to be home.
- Pornhub and Boingboing,
they already got their
360 channels ready
for you to get your,--
- But like,
it's way beyond that.
When you really play it out,
when you actually
think it's happening.
- It's over.
- Yeah.
They have the bluetooth
accessories to go with it now
so you do.
- No, no, that's exactly right.
Like it's over.
And so people will
be like that's so weird,
that's so bad. True.
Go dig up somebody
who died in 1854,
show them the
way we live our lives
and they would think
it's the craziest shit
they've ever seen.
The craziest like, I have no,
these are people
without electricity.
What do you think they think?
Like forget about
cable TV or internet.
They didn't have electricity.
They didn't even
know what a phone was.
Like, they wanna do
something they walk 13 miles.
Or like jumped
on a fucking horse.
So yes, that's what happens.
But we need to
figure out as businessmen,
as entrepreneurs,
as human beings
what are we actually
gonna see and what aren't we.
I do think that happens.
What I don't know
because I'm not educated enough
is is that 50 years away?
Is that 200 years away?
But all the trends point to
a very, very different world.
IBM Watson is smarter than you.
These are real things.
- Watson just helped
write lyrics to a song
and it became a
pop hit, it's nuts.
- Of course, cause
Watson has all the data
to know exactly what
we actually react to.
So here are the
last 8,000 hot songs.
And Watson says
got it, got it, got it.
Okay, here's the song.
- Yeah, 8J the Whiz Kid
or something like that?
- There was
something that somebody,
I always talk about
EQ like my big advantage
is emotional intelligence,
this, that and the other thing.
And somebody sent me a
tweet or a DM somewhere
that showed that computers
now have more EQ than humans.
And I'm like crap,
there goes my advantage.
Technology's gonna keep
taking people's advantages away.
And so we need
to understand that.
It's fun when you're benefiting.
It's fun when
you use the internet
to build the biggest wine store.
But then when wine grapes
are being turned into molecules
and people just lick a stamp
and it's like drinking wine.
It's always fun when you're
on the right side of this.
It's not fun when
you're on the other side.
My big point of
view to everybody
who's listening and
watching is figure out
how to be on the
right side of it.
- [Tat] Stay woke.
- Oh, that's such, yes.
- [Tat] That's how
we say it, stay woke.
- That's it.
- So 2017, what
are you focused on?
What's GaryVee
personally focused on?
We talked a lot about trends.
- Listening to people.
This is gonna air,
you're gonna tell me.
And I'm gonna watch
everybody's reaction.
What part did they like?
Oh they thought it
was cool when I said
Twitter was fucking
chicks in the summer, good.
I may use that again.
Oh, they thought
why did I wear a suit?
That looks shit, oh shit,
I'll never wear a suit again.
I'm a counterpuncher.
What am I gonna do in 2017?
The same thing I did
in 2007, 1997 and 1987.
I'm gonna watch
people's reactions.
You know why I sold a
lot of baseball cards?
I see your handsome partner
Ryan here in the back, right?
Because I would go and
watch how people reacted
to other people's tables.
It would take me
three hours to set up
my baseball card
table because I figured out
the UI and the UX of my table
and what people were
selling or buying stuff for.
I didn't even open up shop.
I walked the
floor of the convention
for four, five
hours and I tasted.
Oh, everybody's pumped
up about the Bo Jackson
black and white scorecard?
Cool, I'll raise the price.
Oh, everybody's selling the
Mcguire USA, I'm gonna do that.
Oh, the '86-87 Fleer Basketball
cards keep going up,
let me not sell
them this weekend.
I react, I always react.
And so what I'll do in
2017 is, I'll pay attention
if Snapchat's really in trouble.
They're really in
trouble if 15 and 19
and 23 year olds get off.
They're not really in trouble
if the views that you lost
were from 45 year
olds that were coming on.
They need to figure that out.
But they're not
in trouble, got it?
So what I'm gonna do
is one of the reasons
to your point
Jesse, earlier is that
I'm putting out
a lot of content.
I've even gone DailyVee
is now daily, right.
And that's a reaction.
Casey, the best video
blogger in the game,
good friend of mine,
I invested in his company.
He stops, I start
the next day doing daily
'cause I knew his
audience had to find people.
I knew a lot of those
15-year-old girls weren't
gonna love me that way.
Because they didn't
care about the business.
That's fine. But if I took
a percentage of that,
that was me reacting.
I didn't know Casey was gonna
retire from vlogging this year.
So that's a
reaction to an opportunity.
And that's the way to do it.
- Yes. What you're doing
is just staying woke
and you're doing
your due diligence.
- I'm woke for the
rest of my life 24/7/365.
- Facts.
- That's the truth.
- That's what you gotta do.
- You want to
talk tech nerd terms?
You know how
there's programs that run
in the back of your
computer at all times?
That's what I do.
I'm running in the
back of culture 24/7.
And what's really cool for me is
I'll be dangerous
enough to come here
and make some references
that make everybody know
that I know what's going on.
I can do the same thing in 800
different little subcultures.
This one's a little more
fun for me 'cause it's true.
But that's what I do.
- That's fire.
I love it, I love it.
- Thanks for having me.
- Listen, we're gonna
bring you back next year
around this time.
- Done.
We're gonna talk
about the same thing.
We're gonna see what happened.
- I'll trying to work
out my Nostradamus skills
to give you something for 2018.
- And big summer jam.
- Yeah, we were talking
before we started filming this.
Let's come up with something.
- We're gonna do
something really dope.
- All right.